mais là julien alors les problèmes donc
avec les seins de sophie marceau
ça risque pas d'arriver avec votre
nouvel album qui sort chez virgin et qui
s'appelle studio et je me suis gouré
voilà ça s'appelle studio et c'est une
surprise puisque vous reprenez je viens
clair dans cet album les grands
standards américains joués par les plus
grands jazzmen du moment et avec des
paroles françaises écrit par les plus
grandes stars de la chanson voilà c'est
pas gentil parce que là il est prêt à se
marrer quand même ce que je voulais dire
simplement c'est que malgré tout ça
standards américains paroles françaises
on dirait du julien clerc le single
s'appelle avant qu'on aille au fond des
choses
avant
chaud
demandait beaucoup
julien clerc avant le maillot pendant
que le premier
extrait de son nouvel album qui
s'appelle studio voilà alors je viens on
va prendre les choses par le par le
commencement
les parents de julien était déjà pas
d'accord sur son prénom de dire que sam
son père voulait qu'il s'appelle paul et
sa mère voulait qui s'appelle alain donc
il s'appelait paul alain paul alain
leclerc alors d'ailleurs vos parents
étaient pas d'accord sur votre prénom
est très peu de temps après votre
naissance ils ont divorcé
le décalage un an et demi un an et demi
oui alors ensuite votre vie julien est
divisé en deux d'un côté yahia votre
père haut fonctionnaire à l'unesco
vous passez la semaine avec hui à
bourg-la-reine dans une maison en
meulière il assez musique classique 1
c'est votre belle-mère donc vous fait
écouter de la musique la cima mise
kim américano aussi voilà ça c'est toute
la semaine et le week end julien le
petit julien est avec sa mère alors
votre maire c'est la branche antillaise
de la famille c'est une femme seule
secrétaire de direction qui laisse dites
vous des traces de rouge à lèvres sur
les filtres des cigarettes réserve s'est
décrit le personnage c'est un c'est une
idée de romancier ça voilà et donc chez
votre mère contrairement à ce qui se
passe chez votre père il ya la télé il
ya des disques il ya des disques de
brassens il ya des disques de jazz c'est
comme ça en fait que vous rencontrez le
jazz à cette époque là il a le premier
disque auquel vous intéresser c'est un
indice de nat king cole qui s'appelle
dream a little dream of music été repris
d'ailleurs depuis maintes fois vous
écoutez aussi sidney bechet et puis
d'autres pianistes de jazz qui par
exemple ces messieurs louis armstrong et
puis alors après par exemple j'écoutais
beaucoup m'acheter des dix d'art tatum
avec beaucoup de pianiste un peu plus
tard bobby timmons thelonious monk un
peu après richard toujours des pianistes
est le premier artiste que vous verrez
sur scène c'est duke ellington à
l'olympia et puis ensuite l'arrivée des
beatles et à ce moment là vous éloigner
du jazz parce que le jazz devient
compliqué devient une musique de
spécialistes vous êtes emportés par par
la vague de la pop british mon pied
voilà après vous oubliez un peu le jazz
on non pas vraiment parce que les
artistes que j'ai toujours aimé c'était
quand même toujours des descendants du
jazz
dre de charles marvin gaye tout tout
tout la soul music
tous les artistes que j'aimais beaucoup
noir américain faisait tous de la même
stevie wonder a fait ses premières armes
là dedans alors ses chansons de jazz
cesser ses tubes ses standards des
années 30 40 50 continue à vous hanter
toute votre vie et chaque fois que vous
en entendez un vous avez une espèce de
coup au coeur nous envie de les chanter
c'est ce que saku d'harmonie aussi ces
lézards les accords et monique et mais
c'est une musique que je connais pas que
mon oreille et mon coeur adore mais je
ne sais pas faire
et donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
que c'est comme un truc qu'il faut
exorciser
alors voila mais qu'elle chantait un
jour votre ami et néanmoins agent
bertrand de labbey vous dit il n'y a
qu'à prendre celles qui ont été chantées
par sinatra donc d'un seul coup ça
permet quand même de classifier les
choses oui parce que sinatra il est un
champion d'arts castille la touche enter
mais c'est pas toujours ses versions à
lui que j'ai préféré oui vous avez vous
écouté les versions de sinatra mais vous
écoutez aussi celle de la fidh gerald de
louis amstrong du vat king cole de diana
krall et même de recevoir récemment et
qui a fait un disque un peu comme bryan
ferry d'ailleurs aussi un disque de
reprises de grands standards de l'époque
donc voila et à un moment où vous
arrivez avec un tracklisting c'est à
dire est qu une liste de chansons il à
vous voulez réapproprier c'est à dire
que voulait jouer jusqu'à ce qu'elle
devienne président du julien clerc s'est
ensuite sans souci que c'est pas un
disque de reprises c'est plutôt à un
disque envie de dire de revisitation
c'est à dire de mettre des paroles
françaises sur ces grandes musiques
éternelle
voilà alors les auteurs c'est maxime le
forestier c'est david mcneil c'est jean
loup dabadie alain souchon benjamin
biolay et carla bruni voilà et ensuite
julien sous la direction de jean claude
petit vous faites ce qu'on appelle des
sessions à l'ancienne ça vous enfermer
tout le monde dans un studio où le faire
plein de pistes les unes après les
autres comme c'est un tout le monde
jouait les moyens car chantal ouais
voilà un alors des jazzmen d'enfer il ya
jean luc ponty
10dans gros philippe katerine tout ici
henman ce qui est vraiment un type
extraordinaire qu un harmoniciste
d'accord le plus grands harmonicistes du
monde présent passé combien 80's comme
un sacré culot de reprendre tous ces
standards croit quand on chante comme
c'est mon cas depuis longtemps on se
doit chaque fois d'essayer de proposer
quelque chose de nouveau aux gens après
le public décide maintenant c'est la
grèce est pas très nouveau justement je
trouve assez une nouvelle façon d'être
complètement nouveau maître du français
là-dessus hésiter vachement quand j'ai
été le premier des critiques là dessus
ce que je connais c'est tellement bien
ses chansons dans les versions
originales que ya vraiment eu un tabou a
renversé pour mettre ça en prendrait
qu'est ce qui vous a décidé à vous
lancer la demande si vous savez quand
même que tout le monde doit l'écouter
sens disant est-ce que c'est aussi bien
ce que c'est moins bien enfin sais pas
combien original
c'était un disque autant que
d'interprètes c'est un disque de
compositeurs amoureux oui on va faire un
test julien vallée au piano